voilà elie semoun alors quand vous avez
décidé de faire se disent que tous vos
amis vos vos parents votre papa tout le
monde vous aviez ne fait pas ce à quoi
tu maîtrises mais oui c'est vrai qu'on a
on m'a déconseillé de le faire ouais et
motivés ça m'a motivé non franchement
oui et non oui parce que c'est mais
c'est pas évident je m'en aperçois
encore maintenant de tu vois là j'ai
l'impression d'être multi cartes je
viens présenter un disque qui d'après
elle les cassettes des petites annonces
passées
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre et je crois
que j'espère que les gens vont pas être
trop déstabilisés mais je crois que je
faisais attention les gens auxquels nos
côtes à égal c'est quoi commence c'est à
17h en direct c'est en direct
je crois qu'on en a trente mille ou 30
millions tout comme ça c'est pas mal et
puis ensuite j'étais allé faire
l'appareil que vous un courage
absolument incroyable il était allé
faire la première partie de laurent
voulzy
ouais c'est pas évident parce que les
gens qui vient d'arriver sur scène
surtout quand on n'est pas chanteur y
compris un petit peu le système lorsque
j'ai fabriqué les gens s'attendaient à
rire non mais c'est vrai mais quand vous
savez c'est un peu spécial c'est vrai je
déconnais entre les chansons pour
essayer de 2 que que les gens me
retrouve dans ce qui me choque dans ce
qu'ils connaissent deux mois mais mais
dès que je commence à chanter ça allait
tout le monde dormait je ne devrais pas
dire ça fait du mal je me fais
franchement c'est très doux avec lui bon
alors vous disiez elie semoun si ça
marche pas j'en ferais pas un deuxième
alors quel est le verdict lé verdict bas
n'ont pour l'instant je ne pense pas
faire un deuxième je pense plutôt faire
un nouveau spectacle mais j'ai beaucoup
de bouche
ils sont marrants et sp.a d'un seul coup
une rafale de haute loire
ça va vite je regarde ton truc comme un
vrai test est moyennement confiance bien
alors c'est que la chaîne france 2 a
fait une étude sont les invités de tokyo
elie semoun et vous êtes parmi les
meilleurs invités de tokyo les meilleurs
clients comme on dit vous êtes en tête
vous savez ça annonçait pas vous êtes
encore faut-il trouver show confondues
en tête mais qui le meilleur client
c'est les gens qui disent ah ouais on
leur a demandé moi jours pour vous quel
est le meilleur qui quels meilleurs
invités on à tokyo à la télé c'est pas
les mecs qui souhaitent un poil qui
montrent leur cul ou qui cassent tout
sur les places où le meilleur a sonné je
comprends qu'on voit souvent à la
télévision parce que effectivement le
meilleur ça va toi sinon bah ça va il
fallait que je fasse une réplique qu'il
fallait que je remercie les gens
question si vous deviez classé deuxième
des premiers l'année dernière pierre
arditi les passer deuxième c'était mal
aurélie on va pas lui faire passer le
test on va lui donner une carte de bons
clients tout de suite allé en tête des
sondages à une carte de bon pied voilà
bien c'est qu'avec cette carte
donc entre le sondage et valériane n'est
pas tout le monde un non sens strict et
y avait longtemps que j'ai pas vu
l'émission donc je me suis fait avoir
c'est ça là je veux dire la vérité
toi tu ne t'y crois pas et pierre arditi
il ya cru alors j'ai dit voilà pierre
arditi ni un sondage qui a été fait par
france 2 sur les bons clients des
tokyoïtes où vous êtes numéro un tout
autre chose
et puis tout le monde on est du registre
est super et on dirait quelque chose
avec ces cartes ont dit les prénoms je
vois les choses c'est nous à chaque
émission vous parlez de dieudonné vous
souvenez c'est incroyable et en qui dieu
n'en est qu'à une époque
non mais c'est vrai un jour de dieudonné
je me souviens un jour se sortait des
chiraquiens beckinsale et uni